GAME.
>> Mike: ANTHONY ABLE TO SPIN
HIS WAY .
>> Brian: NICE MOVE.
JUST FUN TO WATCH.
>> Mike: WINDING DOWN THE FINAL
MINUTE ON THIS ONE.
42 SECONDS TO GO.
TEN ON THE SHOT CLOCK.
SABONIS SWITCHES ON TO FOX.
THAT'S A MISMATCH.
FOX GOING TO TRY TO GO TO WORK
WITH THE BLOW-BY.
>> OH, CAPTAIN BUDDY'S IN THE
PAINT!
HE CAUGHT A COUPLE OF BODIES,
AND SLAMMED IT HOME!
DE'AARON, IT'S THE BLOW-BY.
PUT HIM IN THE HOLE.
GET OUT THE WAY.
FOX FORCE FIVE BIG TIME.
PUTTING AN EXCLAMATION POINT ON
THAT THING, MARK JONES.
>> Mark: I THINK THAT HAMSTRING
IS ALL RIGHT, THE WAY HE
EXPLODED AND JUST DETONATED.
REBOUNDS.
LeBRON JAMES AND JAE CROWDER.
THOSE TWO HAD SOME MEMORABLE
DUELS IN THE FINALS LAST YEAR.
CROWDER FOR THE HEAT.
THEY ARE LEANING ON EACH OTHER.
THIS HAS BECOME PERSONAL FOR
THESE TWO.
CLEARED OUT.
LeBRON WANTS  FROM OVER.
CROWDER.
MET BY HALF.
McDANIELS WITH THE ONE-ON-ONE
MODE WITH THE STRONGER MAN ON
IT.
TERRY ROZIER AND CODY ZELLER
WITH  THE OFFENSIVE REBOUND.
AS THE TIE IT UP BEFORE THE
TIMEOUT WAS CALLED AND THE
HORNETS WILL HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
SIZE ADVANTAGE WITH THIS JUMP
OUT.
AND HERE IS MILES BRIDGES WITH
THE SHOT BLOCKER.
>> Bob: BRANDON GOODWIN IS
COMING IN.
>> Mike:
END BY MOSES BROWN.
THEY ARE STILL KEYING IT OVER
BY YOUNG NATE.
SO GOOD ON THE FLOOR.
TWIST AND TURN.
THAT IS GOING UP AGAINST ADE.
ALLOWED HIM TO STRETCH THE
POSITION.
THEN HE CAN GO TO WORK.
>> Brian: HARDAWAY JR. P ANOTHER
STEAL BY KAWHI!
HIS FOURTH!
BACK THE OTHER WAY.
NASTY! IT'S TIME FOR THE ALLSTA
GOOD HANDS PLAY.
AND MY GOODNESS, WAS IT A GOOD
HANDS PLAY.
FIRST THE STEAL BY KAWHI.
A LITTLE THREE-ON-ONE FAST
BREAK, AND MAXI KLEBER, YOU
ELEVATED AND DIDN'T GO HIGH
ENOUGH ON THAT ONE.
KYLE GUY HAS HAD THE HOT HAND.
>> Doug: THERE WE GO.
>> Mark: THEY CAN TIE IT UP OR
WIN IT ON A THREE.
GUY, GOOD BALL FAKE.
PUMPING FOR THE LEAD.
GOT IT!
THE FINAL IS IN.
KINGS WIN IT!
KYLE GUY.
>> Doug: DOING IT BIG.
I SAID IT WAS BABY.
>> Mark: GOT HIS DEFENDER IN THE
AIR.
AND THIS IS THE MOMENT THAT HE'D
BEEN TRAINING FOR ALL SUMMER.
DOWN IN LOS ANGELES.
BUILDING UP HIS BODY, IMPROVING
HIS SKILL, AND HE SHOWED THE
PREPARATION, THE POISE, THE
PERFECTION.
AND THE PUNCTUATION MARK.
ONNT OFFENSE.
SARA: INSTANT OFFENSE AND HE
IS NOT AFRAID TO LET IT FLY.
IAN: 11 SECOND DIFFERENCE,
SHOT CLOCK TO GAME CLOCK.
DOTSON LOSES IT, WALKING THE
TIGHTROPE.
OH!
WADE GRIFFIN, RAZZLE DAZZLE.
OH, NEXT LEVEL.
KEVIN DURANT, THE RACK ATTACK,
AND ONE OF THEG.
IT'S DURANT THIS TIME, BUT
THIS MAY BE THE PLAY OF THE
YEAR IN THE REGULAR SEASON
FINALE, RAZZLE DAZZLE, FLAVOR,
AND BRINGING THE SPIKE.
THIS IS JUST TOO GOOD,
ASTONISHING. BY ERV
AGO APPROACH THE TWO-MINUTE
MARK AND SECOND OVER TIME.
NOW HE HAS LENGTHY DURING
RANTS.
>> EYESSHOT, THREE BALL, LONNIE
SECOND GAME BACK FOLLOWING THE
WRIST INJURY, TIES IT 83-83.
>> Sean: LONNIE'S LOOKED GOOD
WITH THE BALL, JUST HASN'T
GOTTEN ENOUGH SHOTS.
>> Bill: PATTY MILLS GIVES
LONNIE WALKER -- OH, MY
GOODNESS!
>> Sean:
VANDERBILT, WHO HAS PLAYED IN
ONLY 39 NBA GAMES. HIS SECOND
SHOT IS NO GOOD.
REBOUNDED BY ANTHONY.
TWO SECONDS LEFT.
ANTHONY FOR THE WIND, COLE
ANTHONY  GIVES THE MAGIC A
VICTORY!
IT IS IMPROBABLE! UNSELFISH PLAE
NETS POINT GUARD JAMES HARDEN.
EVERYONE IS WORRIED ABOUT STRONG
PERSONALITIES ON THE TEAM.
THERE IS ONLY ONE BASKETBALL.
THESE GUYS UNDERSTAND HOW TO
PLAY WITH ONE ANOTO JAMES.
BOOGIE WITH THE STEAL.
BACK ON DEFENSE.
PUTS UP THE LONG THREE TO BEAT
THE BUZZER.
GOOD DEFENSE BY THE ROCKETS.
BROWN WITH THE MISS.
KUZMA.
THE H.
>> Bill: 15 POINTS FOR LEBRON
JAMES.
THE BASKET IS GOOD FOR
THE BENCH LOVES THAT.
TACKO, AT LEAST SMILE!
IT'S OPEN NOW, MIKE!
>> Mike: CELTICS WITH 122
POINTS.
>> Brian: AGAIN, DO IT AGAIN.
OH!